[Music]
we have science to thank for
breakthroughs in medicine improving
people's lives and even unlocking some
mysteries of the universe but can
science tell us which movie will make us
shed the most tears stay tuned as we
find out very few people might like
sadness as a concept but there's no
denying that there's a time and place
for sitting down to watch a sad movie
however exactly what constitutes a sad
movie and how it can be experienced is a
more difficult thing to figure out we
all have those certain films that just
tug on our heartstrings some prime
examples include the horrifically
depressing ending in million dollar baby
the haunting journey portrayed in the
pianist and the gut-wrenching conclusion
to the green mile each movie works in
different ways to make the audience weep
for the characters and all are
critically acclaimed for their success
in evoking such sadness thanks to the
large variety of things people convey as
sad and the vast array of films that
depict said things you could say the
list of sad movies is nearly endless as
such if you were to ask someone what the
saddest movie of all time is they would
probably only be able to give you a
subjective answer that is unless you ask
the right people see while it's easy to
assume that it's pretty much impossible
to designate a single film as the
saddest movie of all time smithsonian
magazine's richard chin thinks otherwise
he spotlights an astounding scientific
study by psychology researchers robert
levinson and james gross who have
apparently succeeded in such an endeavor
working at the university of california
berkeley back in 1988 levinson and gross
were researching the relationship
between movie scenes and emotion
specifically they were searching for a
scene that succeeded in eliciting only a
single emotion at a time smithsonian
magazine reports on the sadness front
the winner was as clear as it was
surprising
after testing 78 carefully vetted sad
movie scenes across almost 500
undergraduate volunteers they discovered
that the ending scene in franco
ziferelli's 1979 sports drama the champ
was distilled sadness evoking the
emotion more often than any other scene
to put this in context second place went
to the famous scene in bambi where the
titular character's mother dies since
the results of the research were
published in 1995 the champ has been
used in a great many psychology
experiments and features in over 300
papers this is largely due to the
scene's ability to cause sadness in test
subjects in a powerful yet comparatively
ethical way levinson said it's wonderful
for our purposes the theme of
irrevocable loss it's all compressed
into that two or three minutes curiously
enough despite its off the charts
emotional punch critics don't consider
the champ a particularly great movie it
only has a 36 percent tomato meter score
on rotten tomatoes so while scientists
may be convinced of its importance
perhaps being a sad movie doesn't make
it a good movie then again its audience
score is a respectable 82
so maybe critics just don't like feeling
sad so what makes the champ such a sad
movie well if you know what it's about
it's easy to understand why the film is
custom made to put your feelings through
the ringer the movie follows billy champ
flynn played by jon voight an aging
boxer who's struggling to be a good
father for his adorable son tj played by
ricky schroeder as this is happening the
boy's estranged mother played by faye
dunaway attempts to pry the kid away
from his dad all three proceed to go
through the ringer throughout the
movie's duration in the scientifically
ultra sad final scene billy dies in the
aftermath of his desperate comeback
match in plain view of the distraught tj
who slowly realizes that his father is
dead
[Music]
please tj listen to me he's gone the
heart-rending nearly three-minute scene
consists pretty much entirely of tj
uncontrollably crying over his father's
earthly remains
pretty sad right what's more the movie
has plenty of star power in voigt and
dunaway and young schroeder actually won
a golden globe for his role as the
emotive tj as such you can be sure that
all those sad scenes and dramatic beats
get driven home with five star ability
the end result is so extremely sad that
according to smithsonian magazine even
the scientists in charge of the
experiment weren't immune to its power
james gross admitted i still feel sad
when i see that boy crying his heart out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]